now ukraine says russian forces have
retreated from the eastern city vision
as its troops close in on the logistical
hub the counter-offensive has made
significant gains in the eastern hakive
region retaking dozens of towns and
villages in the past week meanwhile
russia has deployed more troops to shore
up its defenses but the moscow-backed
administration in the kharkiv region
admits the ukrainian advance has been
rapid let's get more on this gabriel
elizonde has been following developments
from out from the outskirts of kiev so
gabe
we're hearing of these significant
advances in the last few hours but what
more can you tell us
yeah this has been a huge and ambitious
military blitz by the ukrainians and it
started about three days ago and it's
just been picking up steam every day uh
for the last three days and now the
ukrainians have uh uh
are on the cusp of retaking the very
strategic and important city of izum
uh just uh
southeast of harakiv city this is a
critical turning point
in this war because isiam was as is a
city of more than 50 000 people it's not
a village it's not a town it is a small
city but it was taken by the russians uh
in march and april after nearly six
weeks of fighting the russians have held
it ever since
and it's been a strong hold of the
russian military for the last several
months they've been using it as a key
transit point on the rail line system
there
to supply their troops uh the russian
troops from the donbass region all the
way into the harkiev region as well
this is why the fact that the
ukrainians have been able to retake it
is so significant it basically means
that the ukrainians have cut off supply
lines to the entire porsche to an entire
portion of the russian soldiers there
and this blitz has really been
incredible by the ukrainians in many
ways or remarkable i should say because
just in a zoom like i said it took six
weeks for the russians over fierce
fighting to take that city it appears
the ukrainians have retaken it in less
than a day the com the the russian front
lines uh have collapsed there's simply
no other way to state it at least the
russian front lines in the northeast
region near kharkiv uh the russians have
been pulling out pulling back the
the the the the the soldiers for the
russians that were on the front lines
that were not well trained and not well
equipped were easily overrun by the
ukrainians
the russian troops that were further
back and more entrenched that did have
more troops and better equipment they
seem to essentially
pull out and run away that's pretty much
the situation that we're seeing in the
northeast and even on pro-russian
telegram channels you are hearing things
like
this was a defeat
clearly we were caught off guard these
are the kind of things that you're
hearing even from pro-russian
onlookers here so clearly the question
now for the ukrainians is is how far do
they go how far do they push this but
right now they clearly have a major
momentum in the northeast and they have
strategic have retaken strategic areas
that are a major setback for the
russians and a major success for the
ukrainians all right gabe thanks for
that gabriel elizondo reporting from the
outskirts of keith thank you